hello everyone and welcome to a game
that just finished and I'm very excited
thrilled even to show you this game it
is Dennis laic versus sashik from round
three of this year's Fay World Cup and
um I'm not going to call it any mortal
game or anything like that I don't want
to overhype it but it features a move
that uh well we could call it an
immortal move it's it's a move that um
sort of a queen sacrifice that can be
followed up with even a rook sacrifice
with even more pieces being sacrificed
and the opponent's king always gets
checkmated in the end so the entire line
has to be avoided uh but then you're
just left with a terrible position so
that's basically the story of this game
uh you guys will decide how you want to
call it and I am definitely taking
suggestions so let's check it out uh
Dennis lazovic has the white pieces and
he opens with D4 radoslav plays Knight
to F6 we have C4 E6 Pawn to G3 uh going
for the Catalan opening and pawn to D5
now uh striking in the Cent Center
Knight F3 and Bishop to B4 with check uh
Bishop to D2 and pawn to A5 so very
standard stuff here nothing out of the
ordinary Bishop to G2 we have castles
and now a very strange move by Dennis
lazav some would even call it a mouse
slip it's not as this is not a uh you
know an online Blitz game this is a
classical game played over the board uh
here most uh people just play Queen to
C2 uh or castles but he played Queen to
C1 and uh okay uh it's also definitely a
moon now the queen also guards the C4
Pawn so if captures you might even be
able to capture with the queen
definitely some sort of top tier
preparation if you want to catch you
know a top tier player like rashik off
guard uh we have Bop back to E7 and now
castles Knight B to D7 and now Bishop to
F4 we have Pawn to C6 and now Rook to D1
and getting The Rook to the D file
nicely aligning it with the queen uh
Pawn to A4 four and now while one might
expect something like Pawn to A3 to stop
Pawn to A3 from black uh nope we have
Queen to C2 now so uh seemingly a loss
of a Tempo just getting the queen to C1
and then to uh C2 but okay it is now as
of move 11 that we have a completely new
game rasov plays Pawn to H6 we have
Knight to E5 now uh sort of stopping the
advancement of the B Pawn is then the C6
Pawn would hang so Queen to B6 and now
we have Knight captur on D7
uh Bishop captures and pawn to C5 now
grabbing more space in the center we
have Queen to A7 and now Knight to C3
putting pressure on that A4
Pawn uh but okay it is nicely defended
by the rook and the queen uh Rook F to
C8 and now Rook a to B1 hinting that B4
might be an idea so Pawn to B6 now uh
forcing white to decide on how to defend
the C5 Pawn C captures on B6 we have
Queen captures on B6 and now uh Knight
captures on A4 so radoslav uh sacrifices
a pawn but he will get a lot of activity
for it we have Queen back to A7 now
attacking the knight uh if you move the
Knight then the A2 Pawn becomes a little
bit vulnerable you can move it to C3 but
of course C5 is coming then the C file
opens up the queen is on C2 so you have
to decide yes you could move it back you
could play B3 uh you could also decide
on Knight to C5 um then it goes Pawn to
B3 and now Pawn to C5 of course you want
to open up the C file the queen is on C2
so Knight captures on C5 we have Bishop
captures on C5 and now D captures on C5
we have Rook captures on C5 attacking
the queen queen to D2 and now Queen
captures on A2 rosov restores the
material balance and now comes Rook to
B2 attacking the queen we have Queen
back to A6 and now comes the the moment
where the magic happens uh here Dennis
plays Bishop captures on H6 and the the
idea is pretty uh clean of course he
wants Rosa to play G captures on H6 and
then he will play Queen D4 to attack the
rook and the Knight and he's going to
win material back with OV having an open
King uh but uh you know chess is doesn't
always work out the way you plan G
captures on H6 and now Queen to D4 if
you play Queen captures on H6 that's
really nothing the Knight will just move
and you don't really have anything if
Rook to D4 going for Rook G4 there's
even E5 and now this stops Bishop uh the
bishop stops Rook to G4 also the queen
is now attacked so uh this would be
terrible uh for white but here Queen to
D4 attacks the rook and the Knight here
and here we reach the position from the
thumbnail this is the moment where rosov
played his move could I don't know this
could very well be the greatest move
roslov ever played I'm not I'm not an
expert on Rosa's games but it is it is
truly amazing how great this move is
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only move that wins the game
for black here while I give you a couple
of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on seeing
50 moves into the future and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Queen to A1 that's right offering
a full queen queen to A1 uh and now look
at this uh White is really spoiled for
Choice here you can capture the Knight
you can capture The Rook and you can
capture the queen so a lot to consider
here and uh uh there's just no easy way
to to handle this you have to do
something about that queen as it puts
pressure on Rook you can't just trade
the uh for example on C5 then Queen
captures on D1 comes with check so what
can you do uh let's see let's see rav's
original idea what happens if we just
take the queen well okay Rook captures
on A1 Rook captures on A1 with check and
Bishop to F1 so what's the idea you
might be thinking well okay let's play
Rook F to C1 we take the bishop here not
really because after Queen captures on
F6 and Rook captures on F1 the king
escapes King to G2 Rook G1 check King F3
nothing really happening here so it's
not that after Bishop to F1 it's
something much more potent Pawn to E5
offering a rook as well along with the
Queen H but of course you cannot capture
if you capture then Bishop to H3 and
there's no way to avoid Checkmate uh
there is one but you have to give up the
queen via Queen to see it with check
uh and then you're just going to be
playing this end game where you are down
a full piece of course this will be
completely winning for radosav so uh
after this uh Pawn to E5 move uh this um
of course cannot be done uh so Queen to
H4 is one move that can be considered
after Pawn to E5 uh but now look at this
now Rook C to C1 threatening Rook
captures on F1 and now if King to G2
trying to escape now you play Rook
captures on F1 and if Queen captures on
F6 now you play Bishop to G4 you stop
the king from escaping via F3 or H3
squares uh but okay it's not a problem
we're just going to create some
breathing room for our King nope Rook to
G1 with check King to F2 and now Pawn to
D for sacrificing the bishop as well uh
you've taken away the D3 square and if
the bishop is captured Rook a to F1 will
be Checkmate absolutely spectacular so
you cannnot uh uh take here you have to
free up even more squares for the king
you have to free up the E2 Square for
the white king but now comes Rook a to
F1 with check King to E2 and now Bishop
captures an F3 with check and look at
this white cannot even uh throw back
material at black because if Queen
captures on F3 black will not take the
queen black will play D3 with check and
now you capture and now you are down a
full Rook so what you will have to do
after this bishop to D3 check is run
away with the King but where if you go
to a light Square then we're just going
to give a nice check and pick up the
Queen on F6 so uh of course winning a
material again and if King to D2 then
just a very nice checkmate with Rook to
D1 check King to C2 and Rook to G2
checkm the pawn here covering the C3
Square absolutely everything is covered
so that's what happens if you capture on
A1 that is rav's original idea and of
course you cannot play that but what
else can we play is there is there
something that can be done here let's
play Pawn to F3 uh it's not like uh
black is threatening anything the White
Queen is defending both of the Rooks so
what if we play F3 just give the king
some breeding room and now the queen has
to move nope now you play Rook to C1 uh
threatening Rook captures on D1 and you
cannot trade if you trade let's say
captures and captures and you go King to
F2 now comes Rook to A1 with Queen to G1
Checkmate or white will have to suffer
severe material loss there really isn't
a way uh to escape this so uh you cannot
trade what you can do is triple up here
you defend the Rook with the queen and
rook and offer a queen trade but now
look at how simple this is uh Ponto E5
you just uh chase away the White Queen
even force a queen trade and after Queen
captures on A1 and Rook captures on A1
Rook captures on C1 Rook captures you
will just be up a full piece and it's
not even going to be competitive yes
white is up a pawn but let's say Rook B1
attacks the pawn and you defend it uh
you can play anything like D4 here
you're going to bring the Knight to D5
then to E3
uh then well you're going to have to
worry about Rook F1 checkmate at at some
point and uh you're down a piece there's
no playing this so that's uh what
happens you cannot capture you cannot
play Pawn to F3 moving the bishop also
doesn't help it runs into the same idea
Rook to C1 so then he said all right I'm
going to have to play the only move that
sort of keeps me in the game that is
Queen to D2 but remember the queen on D4
was attacking the rook and the Knight
Dennis sacrificed his piece for this uh
move Queen to to D4 to Fork the rook and
the knight uh but there's just uh no way
to win material back here just Queen to
A3 and now the Rook is defended Queen to
D4 does nothing anymore and now uh you
have to continue this game and you're
just down a piece you sacrificed For No
Good Reason well it was a good reason
unless Rosa finds a rook Queen to A1 uh
which is uh pretty Sensational so here
we have Rook B back to B1 and just King
G7 keeping the all of the pieces
defended and the is asking Dennis what
do do you have anything more here if not
let's call it a day of course Dennis
will play play on he does have the the
open black king but it's not going to be
easy Rook a to C8 we have Pawn to G5 and
now Knight to G8 defending here Queen to
D4 with check King to f8 the black king
now finds safety in the middle of the
board G captures an H6 Knight captures
and Rook to A1 attacking the black queen
queen captures on B3 and now Queen to h8
with check nicely connecting with the
Knight but the Knight of course is a
tricky bastard so just Knight back to G8
and now Rook to D3 hoping to get the
Rook to G3 but of course radosav will
not allow that he played Rook to C3 and
he was in this position on move 34 that
Dennis lazovic resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
truly truly a sensational game a
beautiful peace sacrifice that could
have uh could have been right uh you
know if ROV didn't find such such a
brilliant reputation with Queen A1 but
after that it just shows that you've
sacrificed your piece for nothing so
here for those of you who like it when I
uh finish the the games you know at
least a little bit uh well let's say you
go Rook ad1 you're hoping for for a
trade here maybe you can get your Rook
to G3 doesn't really work Rook captures
on G3 and after Rook captures there's
Rook to C1 check and after the bishop
blocks just Queen B1 there is no defense
against Rook captures on F1 even if you
try to get give up the r the bishop for
maybe capturing on G8 at some point then
Rook captures on F1 check King G2 and
Rook captures on G1 King H3 now even
Pawn to E5 can be played with check and
we can even deliver a very cool
Checkmate like this queen E4 check King
to H5 and now Queen to G6 we can even
sacrifice the queen just for good
measure since uh it was declined in the
original game Rook captures F captures
with check only move King to H4 now G5
check only move King H5 and Bishop to E8
will be Checkmate so this is one of the
possible ways the game could have ended
not saying it would because I
mean of of course we we know what I'm
talking about but uh you know since I'm
the one finishing it I I should finish
it nicely like this uh so yeah very
nicely played by both of them uh Dennis
uh found a very nice move he found this
tricky tricky line of of the Cataline
where you play Queen to C1 instead of
Queen to C2 then bring the queen back
and then he got this position where he
could play Bishop captures on H6 but it
doesn't work here uh if he just plays
something like Bishop to E3 or Bishop to
E5 or Bishop to F3 it's it's a game it's
a game that's being played but after
Bishop captures on H3 rosov just
brutally and ruthlessly uh refuted this
idea uh I mean absolutely absolutely
incredible so uh yeah okay even this is
not maybe the the the worst thing if
Queen captures an H6 it's still going to
be better for black but after Queen D4
uh now now Queen A1 I mean what what a
move I I'm I'm very happy I was able to
witness this game and I'm even more
happier that I was able to share it with
you guys so that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it very nicely done by
radoslav like I said not not an expert
on rav's games but I do think this is
one of the nicer moves not he that
anyone ever played it's really really
beautiful and especially the lines that
come out out of it the lines that were
not played and that were not seen on the
board were absolutely Sensational uh so
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Daniel Taylor
grid wordss logical letters for iOS iOS
John gear Law Office LLC Mario Milano
and the Brutus on Spotify for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
FED Grand Swiss hoping that we get more
games like these uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day